meet now he's the latest humanoid robot
by French company Alder Baron on display
at Japan's robot
week he's 58 cm tall and uses a mixture
of cameras and motors to interact with
humans he can hear you he can see you
and he can respond I work here in order
to help
you or if he's too tall for your liking
there's Roby Jr he's made by Japanese
toy company Tomy he can talk about the
weather sing and make gestures all for
just
$140 but if toys aren't your thing you
can find the helpful here too with
machines that look after bedridden
patients by lifting them out and even
helping them
walk with 144 companies and 20
universities displaying their inventions
here you may get thirsty walking around
that's where this guy comes in the
robust
Barista there are no plans to sell him
commercially yet though so he probably
won't be serving you in a Starbucks
anytime soon